did some things well
but there's definitely room for
improvement i think
a little bit of once those first
stringers came out there was uh you
could tell in and out of the huddle
some substitution problems so stuff like
that need to get ironed out which is
good to see it's good to get it out
there early to where we can work on that
and make sure it doesn't happen again
baker mayfield looking for ways to
improve his game although it all looked
pretty good right out of the gates for
the number one overall pick in the draft
of the cleveland browns pro football
talk live nbc sports radio nbcsn friday
edition there were 12 preseason games
last night nfl network picked the right
one in the 7pm eastern slot because
saquon barkley the number two overall
pick for the giants facing baker
mayfield the number one overall pick for
the browns even though they weren't in
the game at the same time mayfield got
extensive play tony grocery of espn
cleveland told us yesterday we'd seen
more than two quarters from mayfield and
we did and mayfield in my mind was great
now 11 for 20 does not cry out the same
kind of accuracy that he had at oklahoma
but that's fine it'll come in time just
like the stripes on the helmets will
come in time they still don't have the
stripes on the helmets maybe they should
leave the stripes off the helmets the
way they played last night baker
mayfield getting it done saw a back
shoulder throw at one point what do you
think of that dez bryant i think he
liked it saw the catch and run by
antonio callaway that was a 54-yard
touchdown here it is right here if
you're enjoying the show on nbcsn and if
you are thank you very much there goes
callaway he had an interesting week he
looks like he could be a difference
maker for the browns my god could it be
that the browns are actually in the
process of becoming a team
better than what we've seen the last
couple of years well if you put maker
baker mayfield on the field maybe that's
the case after the game the guy who will
make the ultimate decision as to when
baker mayfield plays hugh jackson he was
asked if he was surprised by how
mayfield performed
i'm not surprised by anything baker does
because i see him do it on the practice
field so obviously the throws he makes
the poise he has you know he
demonstrated all that in college so i'm
not surprised by it um
and again you know this is just his
first opportunity and he'll grow from it
you know there's things he'll learn from
and continue to get better at but i
thought it was a good start for him
okay if you see him do it on the
practice field right the other players
are seeing it too now look i don't want
to take anything away from tyrod taylor
he was five for five for 99 yards and a
touchdown to david and joku and joku had
two touchdowns last night one from
taylor one from mayfield
but
there's just something about mayfield
that was why they were attracted to him
he has that pied piper quality that hugh
jackson talked about he had that thing
at his pro day workout where he makes a
little sound and all the other former
teammates from oklahoma come running
he's a leader it's an intangible quality
that quarterbacks need it is a thing
that allows you to inspire a higher
level of play from the men around you
that's the key there's two ways to look
at this we can compare stats we can look
at how tyrod taylor throws the ball
versus baker mayfield who's making
better decisions who's got the higher
accuracy we can also look at what the
other 10 guys do
when they're on the field and it's hard
to make apples to apples comparisons
when you're facing different defensive
units but
i just i don't know maybe it's wishful
thinking
because we're always fascinated by that
bright shiny new object in football the
rookie that's going to come in and make
an impact and and we want to witness
that we all want to witness a great
story what do you root for word for a
great story it's always a great story
when a young player comes in and makes
an impact right away it just felt
different when baker mayfield was in
there it felt like
like something special is finally
happening for a city and a team that has
not had anything special from a football
standpoint happen in a long time 16
years since the last playoff appearance
only one playoff berth since the browns
were reconstituted in 1999 one winning
season since 2002
it came in 2007 when they went 10-6 but
didn't make it to the playoffs i i just
i i
and and they're gonna screw it up right
they're gonna find a way to screw it oh
come on
i i why i just feel like they should put
baker mayfield on the field and jude
jackson doesn't want to do it unless he
is is pulling off a great con job and
he's making us think that he's not going
to use him and he's ultimately going to
or or maybe he maybe hugh jackson
remember he said in hard knocks this is
my chair and my bus i think john dorsey
may have something to say about it and
it could be that john dorsey eventually
has a conversation with hugh and john's
got a good way about himself it's very
positive he's not going to come in and
he's not going to say hey i outrank you
hugh so you do what i say he's going to
be very positive he's going to work on
he's going to persuade him he's going to
try to get him to understand we we need
this kid on the field we got tyrod you
know if it doesn't work we can we can
put tyrod in but
this kid's exciting he's just exciting
let's see what we can do with with baker
mayfield now in new york there's no such
question about who the starting tailback
will be
it's saquon barkley with the number two
overall pick in the draft the giants
went running back and barkley at least
right out of the gates looked pretty
good first carry 39 yards and it wasn't
an easy 39 he had to earn it it was uh
some cuts here and jump left and move
right and off he went for 39 yards now
he had four yards on three carries the
rest of the night but who cares who
knows how many yards he would have had
if he'd had a full game in which to
operate he had 39 on one carry and
that's all that matters to me after the
game is head coach
pat shurmur was asked what he thought of
saquon barclay's debut
well i love the first run you know if
they could all be like that
but you could see you know
it wasn't too big for him
he's probably played in front of bigger
crowds at penn state you know so you
know it really wasn't
too big for him and i think he took the
next step in his progress to get ready
for the season
look saquon barkley i think is going to
be very good they're going to use him
they have to use him they have to
justify taking him with the second
overall pick in the draft so i think
he'll be fine and i think he'll help the
giants be better now i'm not ready to
jump on board the way chris sims is to
say they're destined to make it to the
playoffs last time i checked nfc chock
full of great teams but they'll be
better than 3 and 13. of course that
yeah that's that's not quite a very
daring prediction it's hard to be worse
than 3 and 13 but i think the giants are
moving in the right direction i think
saquon barkley is going to become a star
player in this league he already is his
jersey was the top seller
even before that 39 yard run now one guy
not impressed by the 39-yard run eli
manning channeling a little bill
parcells it's just a run let's not go
berserk yet it was a good run the
offensive line blocked things well he
had a good cut back it was a good play
and that's smart let's not get too
caught up in this
but you know what eli manning should
want defenses to buy into the saquon
barkley hype because then they'll spend
their time trying to stop saquon barkley
more time for eli manning to operate in
the passing game by the way otto beckham
jr did not play for the giants last
night but manning did and barkley did
and barkley looked pretty
good and
you know stats the giants could have
gone quarterback and a lot of people
think they should have gone quarterback
we don't know what they thought of the
quarterbacks who were available after
baker mayfield was taken number one but
they they think eli manning still has a
few good years left so why not give him
a compliment in saquon barkley who can
help him get more out of his arm and i
think it makes sense if you're if you're
all in for manning i think it makes
sense to get saquon barkley
if you think you're a running back away
but i mean that defense last year mike
had problems they were a bad defense
last year even though two years ago they
were good are you confident that that's
all straightened out everybody's back on
the happy train that's going to take
some time they got to win some games in
the regular season you know the one red
flag i have is this
when pat shurmur was under consideration
for head coaching jobs mike holmgren who
hired him to be the head coach of the
browns back when holmgren was
essentially acting as the owner of the
browns because randy lerner didn't want
to have anything to do with it holmgren
said that his advice for pat shurmur was
to lighten up
mike holmgren's advice for pat shurmur
was to lighten up
mike holmgren's advice to pat shurmur
was to lighten up so hopefully he'll
lighten up hopefully he will have
learned from his experience and he
wouldn't be the first guy who got fired
by the browns as a head coach and then
found his way with another team there's
a guy with
five super bowl rings that he's won as a
head coach the patriots who's been down
that path so we'll see
how it goes but i want to get back to
the browns
and baker mayfield
i i just
why do you make the guy the first pick
in the draft if you're not going to use
him and think about the problem that you
have good problem to have no it's not if
tyrod taylor takes the browns to the
playoffs what do you do
they're already talking about extending
him extending him to be the backup or
extending him to be the starter and if
he does take you to the playoffs do you
bench him do you get rid of him well the
bills did last year it's happened before
but here's the thing
we say this all the time
there are
two types of teams in the nfl teams that
have a franchise quarterback and teams
that are looking for a franchise
quarterback and the sub category in that
is a team that has a quarterback that
maybe can become a franchise quarterback
we're not ready to give up on him yet
because we don't want him to become a
franchise quarterback with someone else
that's the ryan tannehill category and
that was the tyrod taylor category until
the bills decided we're going to reach
for the brass ring and get ourselves
josh allen and we'll trade tyrod taylor
for a third round pick and now the
browns have
two guys right
one guy is never going to be a franchise
quarterback or he would have been
already the other guy very well could be
a franchise quarterback do you not go
all in when that has been
your big flaw
for a generation when you have 27 names
on the back of a jersey all the guys who
have played quarterback for the browns
over the years when the last two guys
you drafted in the first round to play
quarterback were cut after two seasons
on a four-year fully guaranteed deal
do you not embrace the possibilities two
ways to do it you put the guy in bubble
wrap right
like like we're saving the good
silverware for when the pope visits the
house or do we just play him do we just
go with it
and
you know maybe that's the deeper message
that todd haley was trying to make to
hugh jackson the other night on hard
knocks we don't want to live in our
fears don't live in your fears cleveland
embrace the fact that you have a guy who
could be special get him on the field
maybe just maybe he'll be like deshawn
watson last year and just think of how
much better watson would have been
if he had been the guy all along
and i know now tyra taylor's been the
guy it's not too late it's not too late
to say you know what
yeah we we see it you see it we're not
stupid and we're going for it we're
going for it well wait a minute
why was why was tyrod taylor's night not
just as exciting as baker mayfield
taylor was five for five led the team on
a touchdown drive i mean he couldn't
have done any more than he did
because at best tyrod taylor is the
present mayfield is the future he's the
guy who can be a franchise quarterback
tyrod taylor is not suddenly at age 29
gonna become a franchise quarterback and
i hope that doesn't show up on freezing
cold takes at some point in the next
couple of years after tyrod taylor has
won two super bowls for the cleveland
browns i just think that when you
finally get that guy that you believe is
a franchise quarterback you get him on
the field now it may be more complicated
than that it may be that john dorsey
fears that hugh jackson isn't really a
quarterback whisperer and would ruin
baker mayfield so they're saving baker
mayfield for the head coach that john
dorsey wants to hire next year which is
entirely possible but the problem is
if taylor takes the team to the playoffs
hugh jackson's probably going to be
there
i i and not that taylor's gonna take him
to the playoffs i i just i think that we
over complicate the sport sometimes
the answer is right in front of your
face baker mayfield's your guy you made
him the first overall pick use him
you